alright folks I know you're excited to
learn about weather data I've been told
you're excited to learn about weather
data I'm gonna do the first few slides
Tina's going to take over for the ones
that require intelligence and I'm gonna
come back at the end okay
remember that VFR ordinarily is a
ceiling of a thousand feet or more and
visibility of three statute miles or
more that's one of the few things in
aviation that's reported in statute
miles as a visibility as Tina mentioned
earlier a ceiling is a broken or
overcast layer or sometimes if it's
really nasty you'll see a vertical
visibility reported so here are some of
the abbreviations that you might see on
the right in a meet R remember these
weather minimums so you know as a VFR
pilots we're looking at the weather
reports to see if we're going to be able
to maintain these cloud clearances and
generally stay out of the clouds so I
wanted to tell you that it's not quite
as hard as you might think because
computer programs make a lot of what
you're gonna learn about some poor on
the other hand we want to give you the
good fundamentals because what we're
going to show you these are the basis of
what these computer programs are
presenting to you they're oftentimes
getting the same data and spinning it in
some interesting graphical way so we're
going to show you all the fundamental
text weather that people have been
relying on since at least the 50s their
weather graphics you can grab on the web
or sometimes in flight how do you get
the weather on the ground and how do you
get it in the air so most of what you're
going to see in the rest of this
presentation can actually be summarized
by clever
programmers and I think the cleverest
programmer of all is this guy David
Boozer who
taught the class last year and
unfortunately he's taking a jet tight
well fortunately for him he's taking a
jet type rating course right now so he
couldn't be with us but here is whether
spork if you want to ever have a good
illustration of the value of an MBA and
studying marketing just think about the
name for this product of whether spork
let's say we want to go from Bedford to
the Gaithersburg Maryland Airport it's
going to show us this was I think from
Sunday evening it's pretty nasty here at
Bedford I believe that's low IFR that
purple and then here's a marginal VFR
marginal VFR actually sorry maybe maybe
the blue is VFR that's the problem with
color codes anyway you get these symbols
for VFR marginal VFR IFR and low IFR but
here here's the altitude we're going
from sea level up to eleven thousand
feet or twelve thousand feet at the top
it shows you inside this blue area where
the freezing levels are it's kind of a
weird mixed up situation here with this
freezing level here another freezing
level here there's air Mets it looks
pretty scary once we get down closer to
the DC area it's not so bad there's only
one there's only one air mitt and it
looks like we could be you know in the
clear of the clouds up here but this is
a good way to summarize it this already
shows you that it's probably not going
to be wise to go on Sunday at I guess
this was Sunday at 1:00 p.m. okay here
notice on the bottom the time keeps
changing so we're going from Sunday at
1:00 p.m. the middle screen capture is
to go at Sunday at 10:00 p.m. this is
that in Eastern Time and the last one is
to go Monday at 8:30 so you can see from
this already that you know you could
take off from Hanscom field rise up to
1500 feet or so on the right and just
cruise along never even getting inside a
cloud until you land
gatorsburg that's kind of a low-altitude
so you might end up deciding well what I
really want to do is you know find a
hole and go up to about seven or eight
thousand feet and go on top of it all
and come back down
but whatever it looks like you could
probably remain clear of clouds make it
to your destination you're not going to
pass through a lot of air mats over here
let's look at this one in the middle
because it's not quite as terrifying
there's a low turbulence low from the
surface all the way up to 18,000 feet if
it says you know a turbulent pyramid
that goes up to 8,000 that's kind of
normal and oftentimes if you climb climb
to four or five or six it will smooth
out but if the turbulence is forecast to
go all the way up into the flight levels
you know that's a pretty ugly day
they're saying there's gonna be a low
level wind shear from zero to two
thousand feet there's gonna be IFR
conditions and it's gonna be gusting
eighteen nuts so all that's pretty bad
unless you really have to go
here look icing from the freezing level
up to flight level two three zero just a
collection of hazards and but think of
it but also look at how look at the
difference between Sunday and Monday you
know if you just hang out on the ground
and you're patient you don't need a
superior level of skill if you have a
superior level of judgment here's some
more presentations from weather sport
again I kind of love this app you have
all the airports you're gonna fly near
so you go from Bedford to Worcester some
places in Connecticut
I think that's Morristown in New Jersey
Pennsylvania Lancaster anyway on the way
to gatorsburg and it shows you here's
your time of departure you're gonna
depart but hey look we just get to be I
guess that is that does mean yeah blue
must be marginal VFR and then green it's
gonna be windy but it'll be nice VFR
weather so if we just wait a little bit
we won't have to fly through any areas
that are challenging for flight has a
mode where you can ask for your weather
briefing in a PDF format and this is the
first page of that PDF format
shows some of the same ideas there are
these graphics these blue half half
moons if you will for icing you can see
there's a key down here it says icing
severity so up here you've got varying
degrees of ice you probably don't want
to be up there in an aircraft like the
Cirrus it doesn't have the icing
capability so now I think it's all up to
Tina to talk about the exciting world of
actual weather data all right so we're
gonna talk about weather data in the
form of reports as well as forecasts so
what is the difference between a report
and a forecast so a report is actually
telling you what's actually happening so
it's a current weather condition at a
particular location a forecast is you
know a forecast that's a guess as to
what is going to happen so it's really
important to know the difference between
these we now have mark Nathanson up in
the and the back who's gonna be talking
to it for about some really cool stuff
and as we talked about he's an FAA
examiner probably doesn't remember this
but he asked me during my oral exam you
know how do I you know for for a given
piece of weather data is that a report
or a forecast and if it's a forecast how
much should I rely on that or depend on
that and so that's something to really
keep in mind the difference between
knowing what the actual situation is and
what somebody guesses the situation is
going to be and you know of course
depending how far out that guess is it
may or may not actually turn out to be
true so a METAR is a report and so it's
a time stamped so I'll tell you the
weather at a particular time in a
particular location and one thing that's
important to think about when you think
about direction is the way that the wind
is reported so if you hear it so like if
you're listening to the ADA so we talked
about the ADA s quite a bit so you tune
in the ADA's frequency and you listen to
it they're gonna be telling you that
wind direction in magnetic if you read
it on a printed
document it's pretty much always a true
heading and certainly on the internet as
well give you some sources that's like
the same as reading it we already
covered ceiling so I won't get into that
so let's just talk about the breakdown
of a meet our report so I I discussed
that generally for example at Bedford
you might hear the meet are updated
every hour or so and we talked about the
identifier right that you know this is
information whiskey maybe an hour later
it's you know the next as they keep
going through the alphabet and one time
that you might see it updated more
frequently than once every hour so is if
they need to do a special report and so
that's the other type of acronym that
you see there SPE CI and that's if the
weather is changing a lot that's usually
a bad thing it's usually you know you
don't like weather changing frequently
it's probably not something you want to
be flying in but maybe the conditions
are deteriorating that wentest you know
the wind or the conditions or the
ceiling has changed significantly so
they'll update that information so there
are a whole bunch of different
abbreviations when you read these
reports I highlighted a couple in red
you know you could make your way through
sort of guessing okay thunderstorms is
TS it seems kind of intuitive but I
highlighted some that are really really
kind of get you so Hale is gr and mist
is BR someone was pointing out on this
side yeah so mists you know if you just
look at it and you try to think oh is it
broken no broken is B K R so they just
try to trick you with that so I'm trying
to try to keep an eye on those and it's
good to refresh your memory on these so
this is an example of a meet our report
so it you know starts off with the
location and then the first two numbers
the one six are telling you that it's a
16th day of the month and then it's
followed by 16 53 so that's the time and
has a Z 4 time in Zulu we already talked
about how you
you know subtract hours depending on
Eastern Standard Time versus Daylight
Time to get to the current time and then
instead of telling you a heading of the
wind in this case it has variable so
sometimes I'll say winds variable at
about 4 knots in this case and then the
next is the visibility so 10 SM is
standing for 10 statute miles and then
in this case the ceiling is overcast
overcast at 6,000 the next two numbers
you see the 14 / 0 7 so that's talking
about the temperature and the dew point
so who remembers what is dew point yes
so we hear the temperature where the air
reaches saturation for water so what
happens when the dew point and the
temperature are very close to each other
so here there you know we have a 7
degrees Celsius for dew point 14 degrees
Celsius for temperature what if the dew
point in the temperature were much
closer only a couple degrees apart yes
yeah it can be very humid you could be
inside of a cloud or having fog or
precipitation exactly so here's a good
source of weather information so you can
go to aviation weather.gov and they have
a bunch of menu options up there so if
you click on METAR right here this METAR
button it'll take you to a place where
you can request the meet our data and so
it asks for an ID so that's the airport
identifier so in this case i wrote in k
bed which is bedford airport Hanscom
field that we keep referring to and then
you can actually tell it to decode the
data for you so as much as you want to
memorize all of these different codes
and symbols in general practice you can
hit decoded and it'll tell you that you
can look up at the time so you can
actually ask for weather data in the
past and you could include a Taff
what is Taft mean
yes general area forecast that's right
so if you do that and you hit enter it
gets view this data so first thing it
does is it tells you the date at which
its producing the data for you and then
the first is the METAR and the second
here is the TAF and so the meet our here
is telling you the location so it starts
with k bed and then here is the
information raw so you see that data
right here or you can have it decoded so
again the first two numbers two three
that's the date twenty twenty third and
then it gives you the time in zulu and
then they they basically go forward with
all that information so it's defined it
here because it's decoded so you see you
know the temperature dew point so i
actually just updated this this morning
so you could see the the weather and
what it's looking like
now i'll go over to the document viewer
for a moment
oh I don't want the light or maybe we
probably need this okay
qualified personnel are here
I'll entertain you that first meet our
was from PDK anybody know where that
what Eric where that is KP DK
southerners DeKalb yeah Peachtree -
Calvin Atlanta it's the Teterboro or
Hanscom field Atlanta I landed there
once in a diamond star
I had to have the wings taken off in
Florida to fix a fuel gauge I took off
from there and I filed a VFR flight plan
landed at DeKalb and I forgot to close
my VFR flight with my spleen
so the FAA our flight service folks at
the time they start searching for me and
calling everybody and they called the
tower at DeKalb and they said hey did
you see I've 0-5 whiskey Tango in this
and no he hasn't seen it it really
freaked out and I was right there on the
ramp so and I kept silencing my phone
because I was at a barbecue place with
my friend and didn't want to be
disturbed anyway so they had they called
the mechanic who took some wings off and
they told him like the aircraft was
missing it was pretty he was pretty it's
some choice words for me so now whenever
I activate a VFR flight plan usually I
fly you know I do a flight plan at all
its IFR and it close for you
automatically I move my watch for my
left wrist to my right as a reminder to
close the flight plan all right Tina
take it away so this is the for flight
app I passed the iPad around a couple
times so I think you guys have gotten to
play with it this is just a setting
where the Blue Dot is showing where we
currently are and I've actually overlaid
one of those instrument flight plans on
top going here so this is a an
instrumented approach to Bedford but if
I wanted to get this weather data here I
can go to airports and pull up the
airport that I'm looking for and then
you know click on this weather and it
shows me the
the meat our so it has both the raw data
there and then it depicts it and again
blue is showing marginal VFR and so it
explains that what's also nice is it
tells you the weather at nearby airports
as well and then you can also go to your
Taff your terminal area forecast and you
can look at how that is changing over
time oh do you know if you don't mind
click on mos also yeah if you're
planning travel MLS is good because it
gives you weather a few days in advance
so you can decide whether or not it
makes sense to depart here on Friday and
hope to come back VFR on Sunday MOS is
talking about the models so the weather
models and what the outputs are I think
it stands for model output statistics
not very helpful but anyway it's a
longer for flight and Garmin pilot and
some other sources like weather spork
will turn that into a sort of a virtual
tap for you that lasts three days
instead of just 24 hours or 30 for the
big airport so another type of weather
report is a PI rep or a pilot report and
so this is where a pilot could be flying
and wants to report the conditions so
for example turbulence or icing those
are types of things that are frequently
reported by pilots and you can actually
report one as well so one time when
you're getting your your flight
instruction if you do notice wind shear
turbulence icing try to see if you can
actually provide your own PI rep and
I'll ask you certain information such as
your location the time the altitude at
which you experienced it what type of
aircraft I think that's really relevant
because for example wind shear
experienced by a small Cessna is one
thing if a large aircraft like a big jet
a JetBlue aircraft is telling you that
they have wind shear I'd really pay
attention if they seem to have trouble
with it that means you're definitely
gonna have trouble with it and then you
can also have printed weather forecasts
that tell you so we just talked about
the TAF as an example and as Phillip was
just saying it only goes out 24 hours so
you know the same type of information as
a METAR and similar abbreviations and
then we were just talking about that
those models and so you can forecast
even farther out if need be you can also
get a forecast for a general area so
this is what we were discussing earlier
when we're talking about radios and she
might want to call in and ask for kind
of a weather forecaster or weather brief
for a given flight plan we talked about
how you'd call it and kind of give your
tail number where you were starting
where you were going about how much time
you thought you'd be on route or in
flight and then they might tell you the
weather for the general area as well as
the local you know current readings as
well as the forecasts and notice that
these area forecasts if you go to the
page on aviation weather Cove are now
only available for two or three regions
like the Gulf of Mexico they used to
have them
you know for all over the continental US
and they included cloud tops which was
very useful the forecast top of the
cloud because it would say four thousand
feet you would know that if you get as
long as you get on top of those IFR
you're not going to pick up any ice
because you'll be above the clouds and
now you have to try to tease that out of
the mos data sources or use something
like weather spork that tries to depict
graphically where the clouds are I think
for flight its profile that you will
also try to do some of that you can also
get forecasts of winds aloft we talked
about that a couple times and so this
will tell you kind of what the winds are
going to be at a particular altitude and
you might for example at 3,000 feet or
6,000 feet and so you can it helps you
estimate especially in a cross-country
flight or a longer flight how long it
might take for you to get there on on
apps such as for flight if you in fact
it'll just we'll just do that right now
so you can see
[Music]
so you can actually enter in a sort of a
flight plan very quickly so you can have
a starting a starting place and then
so where do you guys want to fly to
that's a pretty short flight if I'm sure
you guys if you have the patience to
stay with us tomorrow afternoon starting
at 3 o'clock the founder of four flights
going to be here
and I'm sure you'll get a pretty
thorough demo he's gonna be in the
collar you're gonna talk for a couple
hours about you know first the app and
also the startup and then some of the
engineering behind it so the blue dot is
showing where we are here at MIT but of
course generally you'd be doing this
when you're at at Bedford and you're
flying to to Logan and then here it's
telling you it wants to know about the
aircraft that I'll be flying in order to
calculate some of the some of the
information but when when you do these
types of things with the flight it can
estimate kind of how long you'll be in
flight and when you and you can provide
what is the altitude at which you want
to fly and then it will be able to so it
says colouring based on winds aloft if
it looks like it's not detecting that
may be because I haven't given it all of
its data right now so in terms of what
that means is just that the the winds
aloft are a good way of helping you
predict how long it's going to take you
to get to certain places and it'll be
part of the cross-country planning all
you have to do the winds aloft forecast
also shows you the temperature which is
critical because that's going to tell
you whether icing is icing is not
possible if it's above freezing
generally they're also a bunch of severe
weather reports and Philip has already
talked about a number of them air Mets
and signets as he was talking about so
here's you know and then they they have
different abbreviations so even more
abbreviations related to this so what
what they mean for icing and turbulence
so here
we'll look at some examples of an air
met and in the picture kind of shows a
broad area where that air met is valid
and so this is talking about icing and
freezing level this is a so Sigma DH
also talked about how they're hazardous
weather such as icing turbulence
volcanic ash which I don't think you'll
encounter very often but you know was an
issue in Europe for example and then
here's a breakdown of decoding a signet
as an example to show you the type of
type of information what it stands for
and and you know you can read through
these to understand the adverse weather
and certainly if you're planning your
own cross-country flight I recommend you
also use your normal weather data
sources as well so just turn on the
Weather Channel or weather calm or a key
weather whatever you you use on a
regular basis if it's a crummy day it's
probably not a good day to go flying
anyway and you may not want to dive so
deep into all of these different tools
but if it seems like a nice day then I
would really recommend diving more
specifically into understanding if
there's a front coming in or other types
of issues and then convective to sigmet
SAR really really concerning so there
there are things that are much more
severe so you're talking about
thunderstorms hail some things you
really don't want to be flying during at
all there's a lot of different ways that
the weather is also produced not in a
text form but in a graphical format so
this is a relatively complicated weather
depiction chart so roll break it down in
detail but let me just tell you some of
the main things do you have the oh I
left it over there thanks Phillip so can
anyone guess what all the little circles
are we see some circles that are white
and some circles that are black does
anyone know what those are
any guesses weather stations good guess
so it's actually trying to tell you what
the cloud cover is like so you can see
certain places where there is the circle
it's empty is that there's it's a clear
day when it's fully filled in that it's
showing the cloud cover and then you see
some that are like little pie charts so
that they're partially filled in so the
purpose of looking at a weather chart
like that is just to get the general
conditions there's a lot of different
things so here it's more specific so
it's you know breaks down that the
circles indicate the percent cloud cover
so if it's a quarter fill that's saying
few clouds if it's three-quarters filled
it's broken and then it also has shaded
areas that depict what the when you have
the IFR conditions so zooming in you can
just kind of see the circles a little
bit bigger and the charts provide a lot
of information as well but you can see a
little bit more clearly also here some
of the circles that are like pie charts
that showing how much they're filled in
and what the what the cloud cover is
looking like and again you can actually
get the same type of thing on your for
flight it's basically an option for
every Airport that it depicts it can
show this cloud cover as well you can
also look at a radar summary chart
they're a bunch of prog charts so they
talk about when you're looking at a
front you've seen you guys have seen a
lot of these things on the on the
Weather Channel probably didn't pay
attention to them very much but it's
good to understand what the different
types of fronts are what's happening
across the country more than just your
particular region so if you're planning
you know if it's a I think today is a
Wednesday so if you're planning on a
flight this up
weekend and you want to think about
what's gonna happen basically you're
trying to see are there some fronts
coming in what's happening or is it
likely to going to be a clear day and
then of course as we've talked about all
of these have good legends just like we
talked about the sectional chart quite a
bit and the details of the legend it's
always good to take a look at how they
have indicated these different lines
where the Front's are and you really
want to know which ones again are
reporting the actual conditions versus
which is a guesstimate of what's going
to happen in six hours 12 hours from now
again if it's a forecast it could be
wrong and then this is just a little bit
more detail of types of things you can
see on a chart I think the most
important thing to look at is this this
weird little R symbol with kind of an
arrow at the bottom it's it's indicating
thunder so that's a big a big one to
look out for if you see that it's
probably not something you're interested
in flying in I'm not for sure and then
there are a couple charts here that are
not specifically on the you know usually
gonna be asked about but it's good to
see so you might have seen these kind of
surface analysis charts and they talk
about high pressure areas and low
pressure areas and so that high and low
pressure what are we talking about so
that's that's the same thing is that
pressure that you're dialing into your
altimeter right so we talked about 29.92
but you know there might be a day where
it's really dropped very low and it's
it's to eight or something very very low
that means you're in a low pressure area
and if it's very high you know you're at
thirty point something you know it's a
higher higher pressure area and if you
see that as you're flying around that
that that pressure setting is getting
updated very rapidly and changing
rapidly
that usually is related to a change in
your overall weather system so you
really want to be aware if that number
is changing quite a bit that's a big a
big problem you can also take a look at
when you get into your airplane and
you're first setting that dial when
you're sitting on the ground you know
see how much is changing it might you
might want to in general when you get
into a plane I like to think about when
the plane was
last flown you can their parts where you
are checking the oil that you can kind
of generally feel the engine and see if
it's warm or not if it needs to be
primed or not those types of things if
you see that the plane has just been
flown and you're really dramatically
having to change that pressure setting
that means the weather has recently
changed quite a bit it makes you want to
really make sure that your projections
and your knowledge about the weather is
still accurate
you want to mention these these numbers
here are the metric equivalents so
instead of 2 9 or 9 or 2 you'll see you
know a thousand millibars or so so we
have a bunch of these you can and all of
these are also on that first website the
aviation weather gov you can look at you
know actually seeing the the clouds from
a satellite picture and kind of just
seeing what what's going on you know
these aren't these are hopefully not the
first time you've seen these types of
charts before and then this is a way
that they like to depict the winds aloft
so these little lines and then depending
on how many lines are coming off the
side it indicates how you know how
strong that wind is and what the what
the amount is so you can see here some
that have a lot of little dashes coming
off of it whereas some that don't have
any it's a way to very quickly see where
the wind is very strong and where it's
not
and this is what I had talked about last
time when we're in the radio section in
the radio ATC and communications section
but just as a reminder this is the
number that you can call and you can get
your full full weather briefing done
there can you want me to take over now
sure this is
all right so Thank You Tina covered the
stuff that requires a brain now I'm
gonna just tell you about you know how
do you how do you get this stuff as a
practical matter you can call this phone
number it's very good when you're a
novice pilot again think about crew
resource management the weather briefers
are another person that you can pull in
they may say VFR flight not recommended
that's there at the bottom that's worth
paying attention to
they used to work for the FAA they were
outsourced in 2005 and now there are
contractors from a company called leidos
so you might hear the name leidos you
can get a full weather briefing over the
phone I actually do this sometimes if
I'm if I'm in an uber on my way to the
Gaithersburg Airport I'll just call the
weather briefer and it makes life very
easy
okay so aviation weather gov as we
mentioned earlier has all the charts
that we saw the weather briefers
themselves are on their own website
which is a little bit of a twist on that
I kind of like this site actually
because you get to set up a homepage
where you pick your favorite Airport so
I picked Bedford Teterboro which is
where you go in the New York metro area
if you enjoy paying eight or nine
dollars a gallon for gasoline and then
Dulles Airport where the two the two
competing FeO is also charge nine
dollars a gallon for gasoline but anyway
they'll have the meet ours for your
favorite airports and the taps and all
this and these you can set up these
charts so basically as soon as you log
in you get a whole bunch of current
weather information that's kind of a
nice feature for this this website and
it is free they will give you just like
aviation weather gov they'll give you
the meet our here's one for Bedford from
the other day I guess that's from the
21st yeah when was three one zero so I
was on the 21st at zero two five six ulu
so it was late at night early in the
morning in London when was three one
zero at 18 knots gusting 25 10 miles of
visibility clear
temperature was minus one one dewpoint
minus one Niner altimeter two-niner four
seven and there's a remark the peak wind
was three one zero at 31 knots and that
happened at zero two two five Zulu time
okay there are private websites the most
popular free one is probably flight plan
comm at least among the turbine crowd
they have very accurate models for a lot
of jet powered or turboprop aircraft and
they have some example briefings that I
think I do want to show you okay
again you'll you'll have access to this
so one nice thing about flight plan comm
is they start you off with an a vlog
remember we talked about that and in the
nav flog they tell you what magnetic
course to steer I'm sorry they give you
the magnetic course sorry May then it
courses three or three I guess they
don't give me the wind correction angle
or maybe the winds right in our faces no
it's not maybe this is not such a great
sight all right
well anyway they tell you roughly how
long it's going to take you to get there
and they will calculate your ground
speed for you so I think I put it in a
piper warrior or something so this is a
pretty low airspeed 124 knots and you
can see the different altitudes
how much fuel you're gonna burn and how
long it's gonna take you so it's really
there's really not a lot of difference
you can see here you could go at 10,000
feet and take 58 minutes you could go at
4,500 feet and it would take you an hour
so there's not a lot to choose from your
airspeed goes up a little bit as you
climb higher but the wind is also a
little bit stronger
they're giving you the weather to go
from Bedford to Bennington Vermont
giving you a little bit of information
about the runways you can look at the
approaches their departure Aircast
aircraft Airport forecast so look at
this departure Airport NOTAMs they did a
pretty good job here they pulled out the
most important note and they were doing
snow clearing so Bedford they said look
runway 1 1 2 Niner is closed except with
one hour of prior permission to this
phone number how about that look at all
this leather NOTAMs you can really get
lost because they're telling you about
stuff you know taxiway here let's go
here taxiway November edge markings
obscured maybe by this little snow I
don't know why anyway that's probably
not really important that maybe it's a
taxiway that you're not even going to
use so this is actually a pretty good
computer program I think because they
put that closed runway no Tim right up
at the top where you might actually see
it and they put it in boldface anyway so
that's a flight plan calm weather
briefing let's see how for flight
presents the same information you saw
that before they also give you this wind
temperature and turbulence oh this is a
firt to a different spot this is to
gatorsburg
significant weather from flight level
two five zero two six three zero not
going to be able to use that in the
Cirrus unfortunately that's up above
25,000 feet we get the meet ours it
looks like sorry the the meet ours and
Taft so we get our meet our four hands
come and it looks like they put in
boldface the relevant portion of the TAF
so they're saying look at your flight
time this is the one that's going to
apply it's going to be better than six
miles of visibility but overcast at 800
so not a bad IFR situation as long as
you can handle any icing and they've
color-coded a bunch of stuff so you can
see here at Worcester they've got that
looks pretty nasty
they're forecasting for example wind
zero three zero at 1 1 knots only half a
mile of visibility Tina helped me out
what's minus PL freezing fog I don't
know what minus PL is but it sounds bad
overcast 500s that are calling that low
IFR
where are the NOTAMs let me see what
they did with the NOTAMs I think that
was the same day ice pellets okay well
we don't want that so this is an
interesting thing for flight kind of
missed I think it was out there maybe
it's here okay so up at the top it says
runway five two three is closed which
normally wouldn't bother me at all
because that's the crosswind runway and
we don't like to use it unless we have
to
maybe that note am was not out at the
time that I got this one yeah there's no
there's nothing about that PPR I guess
they hadn't started plowing the snow at
that time anyway so the NOTAMs are
important they can tell you if the
airport is having some kind of
construction going on mobile apps for
flight is for the iPhone or iPad only
that's a major difference between for
flight and Garmin pilot nav Monster is a
fun free app it works at least on iOS I
think on Android as well that gives you
a lot of good stuff weather spork is all
three plat platforms so we're just going
to show you four flight in case you're
not able to come to the talk tomorrow
starting at 3:00 there's a little flavor
of for flight notice that in the airport
information page here on the left they
highlight the fact that runway fly at
five to three is closed by NOTAMs so
they're making an attempt to pot the
most significant runways but actually a
missed one look at this runway one one
to Niner is also closed except for this
one our prior permission somehow that
exception you know didn't get the
software excited so if you showed up
actually this is a good example of when
you might want to run your minimum fuel
burn maximum endurance airspeed so you
get to the airport and you didn't check
the note hams or maybe it was a newly
issued note am and they tell you the
runways close and it won't reopen for
another half hour so in that case you
know you're gonna go out and loiter
somewhere until the airport reopens
unless you want to land somewhere else
okay
the next page is apparently about NOTAMs
and over on the right we have the
weather which Tina already showed you
and that you see the density altitude
look at that
it's minus 2500 feet it's 2,500 feet
below sea level at Hanscom field for
flight can give you the TAF and the MLS
as I show said so this was I think on
Sunday and have a look there we're
getting the weather for Wednesday so we
can plan our trip to return today
Wednesday and look the MLS is pretty
right it's nice it's a not too much wind
1 9 0 at 5 knots
overcast above 12 below 12,000 here's
Garmin pilot Carmen really believes in
the old white on black like in 1970s
monitor for flight will actually flip
into sort of a style like this at
nighttime and this one it doesn't
highlight for you it's the same time as
I was using for flight and nowhere in
here this is a highlight that runway 5 2
3 is closed or that two-niner is having
any kind of issue I think it was the
same time I could be wrong yeah see 5 2
3 closed runway 1 1 2 9 closed except
one hour prior permission so you're fat
dumb and happy looking at this page
getting all ready to go to Hanscom field
and then if you don't check the NOTAMs
you discover that there's no runway so
i'm not a good reason to always have
some reserve fuel and not over commit to
your plan alright in flight weather
sources there's something called t web
transcribed weather broadcasts you might
be asked about it on the exam I doubt it
anyway in that old that's my friend Eric
again with his dc-3 if you were flying a
dc-3 in its prime you might have heard a
T web hi Ross is still being broadcast
off of certain vor s that are indicated
on the chart so look at this see that H
symbol there in the middle that H symbol
tells you that if you tuned into this
vor and tell your audio panel on the
airplane that you want to
actually listen to whatever's being
modulated that you'll hear this
pre-recorded weather announcement about
maybe thunderstorms in a certain area
you can call flight service enroute
they're very helpful they all take a
pirate from you and they'll tell you
what is going on they can call your mom
if you're going to be late
due to forecast statements I was
actually flying through New York on my
way to do you see and there were
horrible headwinds I was in a diamond
star which is not a very fast airplane
so when you've got a 50 knot headwind
you slow down to Honda Accord speeds so
I asked New York for a frequency change
to flight service and they say well why
do you need it and I said well I want to
have him call my mom and tell her I'm
gonna be late and they said oh we can do
that for you so in between vectoring the
air buses out to Germany they were
calling my mom I think each controller
in New York has an assistant right next
to him or her and actually made the
phone call you quick note
the last point there so flight service
can accept your PI rep so when we talked
about how you should make a pilot report
or PI rep you can call them and tell
them hey I experienced turbulence I
think if it's really ugly you can the
controllers can also put it in like if
it's icing or wind shear they usually
accept because wind shears such a bad
thing and you're fighting the wind shear
and trying to deal with the wind shear
Seville usually except that PI rip
alright next read so in this is actually
this is an actual photo of our Cirrus
screen on our way to Oshkosh so remember
I showed you that one earlier which was
the track from fly to air so we had
planned to go from Rutland Vermont oh
sorry we had planned we'd planned I
guess yeah we came up with a new plan we
really wanted to go from Bedford over to
Syracuse and I think initially we
decided that going to Rutland would keep
us away from the rain radar remember the
radar the NEXRAD radar what they're
really seeing is water
the clouds so they can they can actually
see rain they can't see a cloud that's
just vapor and it's going to produce a
rain storm at some point they're really
seeing the big water droplets of rain
anyway so we elected to fly over here
and refuel at Watertown you are
consented at Syracuse Roxana was on that
flight we flew through some of that rain
and actually what's pretty smooth so we
probably could have just charged through
but we took a more conservative route
okay so next rad data instead of paying
for a receiver in your airplane and then
paying a subscription fee the FAA will
give you next rad data as well as a
bunch of other stuffs like some text
weather data that's another good reason
to be able to read me tars because if
you're looking at it in the cockpit it
could be on a pretty small display and
the RAW format is very compact and
actually very convenient for in-flight
use anyway here's a little diagram of
how its transmitted you have to have
this you have to have let's see if yeah
we talked about this yeah so you have to
have a UAT receiver to get these data
the aircraft position see the big
airliner transmitting on 1090 megahertz
extended quitter it's called that's fine
but you need to be able to receive on
978 megahertz which is this alternative
frequency that I guess had more
bandwidth available and that's where the
FAA can push all these data up to you
like about other traffic even traffic
that doesn't comply with a DSP although
by January 1st of next year you know
almost everybody will have a DSP out at
least anyway so the the feds are pushing
the stuff up to your airplane I'm going
to turn it over to FINA now to talk
about yeah so I just added in this slide
this is the one that we had been talking
about if you want if you're in a plane
that does not have the a DSP receiver
but you want to receive that information
so that you get real-time weather
information or real-time
traffic information you can actually
make that happen by building it yourself
and I did that it really doesn't take
very long if you if you want to seem
really cool you can go and buy the you
know just a regular Raspberry Pi and a
couple different parts also that link
will show you how you can just buy a
little kit where they've put everything
together and you just buy it it's very
easy to assemble so it just has a little
Raspberry Pi inside and it has a little
cooling fan and then it has these
antennas the strattice software is
actually kind of free open-source
software and it's really great and it
syncs up to your to your other apps so
for example with for flight it just
shows up like a Wi-Fi signal that you
connect to and then while you're in the
air when you don't have access to this
data this will actually update so you
can see on the right is kind of a doomed
in picture from for flight so it shows
that you know you can see kind of the
weather on the bottom left corner and
then you also see these little these
little pictures that show traffic so
yeah so exactly so on the farther bottom
right you can also see so it just shows
you other other airplanes other traffic
and kind of the altitude that they're at
and so it's really useful I think it's
kind of nice to have especially in a
little airplane to have that visibility
and knowledge that you're not just
relying on flight service giving kind of
like a area controller giving you
traffic advisories but you can see it in
advance we're about to dive into human
factors and philip has talked a lot
about using the person sitting next to
you whether they are actually a pilot or
just a friend even just a friend can sit
there and hold the hold the iPad and see
the little blue traffic and then when
they hear on the radio that someone's
saying you know hey look it looks like
in this situation no traffic three
o'clock you're trying to look for that
plane well they can have a little sense
of okay yeah it's near that and then
they can help you find the other
aircraft so it's very helpful
how much were the parts for that Tina
it's it's like eighty dollars okay yeah
so the ones that you can buy
commercially all packed
it's like the Stratus I think this is a
play on Stratus issues one of the
competitors in that market they're
anywhere from $400 to $1,000 they think
they those are the commercial ones also
have an electronic jot a gyro in there
in a [ __ ] attitude and heading
reference systems so they can actually
give you on your iPad an attitude
indicator and some information about
your speed and so forth all right so
this is a reminder too that again you
know all that all those data are
intended to help you fly within the VFR
weather minimums which provide a good
margin of safety I put this 20 dollar
magazine up here for you guys because
this whole talk has really been about
software and different ways of spinning
the same data so this is everything in
case you're not a course 6 major this is
everything you need to know to become a
programmer in one twenty dollar magazine
so we're running a little behind so I'm
going to go straight to human factors
while I'm pulling it up let Philip know
if you have any more questions yeah
anything going on
how do you know if your weather briefing
is adequate the the professional weather
briefers at leidos at one 800 w x brief
they tend to go a little above and
beyond they'll give you NOTAMs about any
vor that's out of service on your route
of flight even if you're navigating with
the gps so if you're at all unsure just
you know do your web do your
self-service stuff online and then just
call 1-800 WX brief and ask for a whole
briefing it won't take you more than 10
minutes and you'll definitely be at
least oh you'll probably be over briefed
at that point I'll tell you about on the
tower even if you're flying you know at
noon and it's you know there's no
possibility of it being dark and the
lighting on the tower making a
difference
you